hello
today i'll be speaking about the big
benefits of small data
my name is christopher lozinski i live
in captivitz of poland and you can find
the slides at forestwiki.com
slides forestwiki.com slides
so the first question is what is small
data if you take a look at wikipedia
they have a wonderful definition
the term big data is about machines and
small data is about people
by alan bonde and so in fact in this
application
every single day piece of data was hand
curated by a human
and the different parts of the data were
looked at by
literally hundreds of thousands of
people during the most recent
presidential elections what is the
application
well this is the green party maps
application at first it looks like a map
but really it's a data model of a large
distributed organization
you can visit the website at
map.howie2020.tech
let me repeat that map.howie2020.tech
so what are we going to talk about today
we're going to start about discussing
why we use hierarchy for small data
we'll take a tour of the green party
maps application
i'll tell you a little bit more about
the hierarchical software model
and then we're going to get to the core
of the talk what the user's experience
was with it
what we learned about small data and
some concluding remarks
so why do we use hierarchy for small
data well the basic principle in human
factors is that
there should be no more than about seven
items in a category
so if you have more than that you end up
with a tree a hierarchy
and this is why we organize
organizations and we have hierarchical
charts for organizations
small data is often hierarchical the
largest small data i know
set that i know of oh there's the
library of congress but the largest one
that people use a lot
is the um awesome data sets on github
here we have the awesome data science
sets
and they're organized as a tree it's
just it's much easier for people to use
and understand in that way
and more recently json schema has become
very big if we take a look at this on
the left hand column
we have a json definition of a schema
on the second column we can generate a
user interface in javascript on the
client and not using
a number of different client libraries
and then that data is
validated on the client against the
schema so you get really fast
interaction for the user and then you
can submit that json to a server
you can generate the json you can submit
it to a server and in column four we
validate it on the server just to make
sure that nobody does anything tricky
and then finally we can update the
database so json schema is a tree and it
defines
a tree of json for the data very
powerful
growing in popularity
and actually i will show you a form that
was generated using json and
on the right hand side you can see a
little piece of the very
rich and large uh json schema for this
application
and what's the application well this is
the green party maps application
so let's take a look at the application
and i need to switch you
to
there we go so here we have the map of
the u.s green party again it's at
map.howard2020.tech
and we have filters so here we can see
just the candidates here we can see the
parties in the candidates
here we can hide the candidates
it's organized as a tree you can think
of it as a file system
but really it's run on an
object-oriented database written
in python optimized in c so let's click
into california
you can see this year's suite of
candidates
here you can see a map of california
here you can see uh detailed contact
information for california and there's
lists of politicians
and parties you can click into
so let's let's click into this let's
zoom in a little bit here
let's see i think i need
put the local parties on and here we can
see green party of santa clara
okay so here at the santa clara level
you only see the candidates that you can
vote for
at the local level and so in this case
it's the president vice president and
jake tonkel who's actually in san jose
and again we can see the contact
information
and we can continue to drill down into
this tree so let's
click into jake tonkel
um every page has a logo but what
would jake donkle for his logo is he's
added his picture
and while it's written in python we have
class inheritance
but in this case we also have data
inheritance so any branch
of the tree inherits those data inherits
what we used to call acquisition
of its parent logo and you'll see that
the children of this
all have his image
and again you can see all the contact
information for him and you can see that
um his information we also have a
virtual meeting
so let's click into his virtual meeting
and we this this is a different content
type it's a virtual meeting and you can
see
that he's got two videos here and so
we're clicking to the videos
and in the upper hand left left hand
corner you can see where we are in the
tree we'll come back and discuss that
again in a moment on the slides you can
see the video this is again a different
content type
but maybe you're not happy with the
content here and you want to edit it
so it's a content management system we
can add some
lorem ipsum
and it's a typical wysiwyg editor you
can do italic and gold and strikethrough
and different font sizes and you can
then save all of that and you can view
it
and there you there you have all of
those changes but oops of course this is
the production website so we
really don't want to be making those
changes to the production website
but it's based on a good content
management system the forest wiki is the
first custom to clone
and so we can take a look at the history
and we can
restore it and now when we view it
all is back to normal
so let's go back up i'll show you two
more things
um one is that
you have to there's a large number of
contributors an increasing number of
contributors here
and one of the things is we need to keep
an eye on all of them
so it's actually a management view where
we can see who's made what's changes and
here's some
changes that people have submitted but
we need to approve them
okay that needs to have to check that
after this and if we go back
and we can also see here there's
actually a news site
so it's a tree and it's being updated
all the time and so the end users can
look at any branch of the tree and see
the news for that site so that's a
really important feature too
okay at this point we are going to
return to the talk
so we saw that this was not just a map
it's also a directory
because every node in the tree has
contact information
um you can take any branch of the tree
and build a
website out of it i'll show you that
later you can see it's news
and in the santa clara we saw that there
were the recommended voting lists
they could endorse third-party
candidates and
so that make it easier for people to
know how to vote and it's a content
management system there's also a discord
server i didn't connection i didn't show
you
okay so having seen the application
let's take a look at the hierarchical
model
uh the forest wiki is it's built on the
forest wiki that's the first cousin to
plone
and a lot of these ideas come from clone
community some build on what's possible
and
so the first thing is we have traversal
we have a tree of objects and we have to
refer to the object
so we start on the root and then we
traverse to the map
and from there we can traverse to map
slash california
map california santa clara but the
problem is when you rearrange this tree
your
urls are going to change and so that's
that's not very good
so we also have something called
canonical urls so the root is again
slash or we can call it root
one level down is math two levels down
with canonical urls you can just reach
them directly using slash california
or directly with slash decant santa
clara and further down directly with
jake tonkel
so this is a second path from the root
to a particular node and that really
makes this a graph database
this is running on an object graph
database
but for simplicity for the end users
they generally don't see that it's a
graph database they just see that it's
a hierarchical database makes it much
easier for
users to manage understand
and then it's a lot of this is the plone
is code taken from
pyramid um and so you traverse to an
object either by traversing all the
paths or by using canonical urls and
then you have views on those objects
so here we have one view which is a map
here we have the edit view here we have
the newest items this is news view here
we have that management view that i
showed you
and then there are a whole bunch more
views for manipulating the tree on the
left hand side
you have for managing the tree and on
the right hand side for adding different
content types to the tree
so those are views on objects
let's talk a little bit more about the
herakle model of the green party so in
this case we have a route we didn't
even visit it at the second level down
second row you have the green part of
the u.s and the only candidates who are
present at that level were the president
of the vp
candidates because anybody in the
country can vote for them
at the third level of the tree you have
the state party and we store
the governors and senators there because
anywhere everybody in that state can
vote for them
but nobody in any of the other states
should really see them
and then finally we have local party
counties where all other
candidates are stored so that only
people
who can actually vote for those
candidates end up seeing them
okay so that's the basic article model
of course it's way more complex than
that but that's just to give you the
core concepts
and then now with this json schema when
you come to an individual like jake
tonkel
you see that he has he actually has a
tree of data underneath him
so you can see the tabs his introduction
connect candidate info elected official
party officer volunteer those are each
different branches of the tree
not everybody has every branch but
connect pretty much everyone has this
branch of the tree issue which is the
connect which is basically the contact
information for that individual
so that's all based using json schema i
really love json schema
and the other thing is because it's a
tree you can take any branch of the tree
and generate an instant website so um
on the right hand side you can see one
of the instant websites for candidates
and so next year as the
new politicians arrive and they want to
they're not sure if they want to run or
not we say listen just fill out a form
boom if you have your first pass of your
website so that's really makes it easier
for them to get started
okay but there's a lot more to this data
model
there are really a lot of different
classes that went into this so let's
take a look
first column the basic content types
from the forest wiki
you have a wysiwyg page with the wysiwyg
editor
a title and a brief description of the
woozy wig text
for the data scientists there's also
markdown pages where you can edit the
content using markdown and it generates
the html
caches that for you
we have links they're tree of links
youtube videos you saw
online events you saw online
organization you didn't saw logos you
saw
banners i don't think you saw we can
also add file store just basic content
types for any file management system
then there are a whole suite of types
for managing maps
originally i worked on google maps i
don't like that they track everybody
now open street maps i suspect they also
track everybody
mapbox and then
remember the geo json map so the outline
of every state you can click
into a state and so that's using geojson
data
we have the organizations those would be
the state parties the local parties and
the caucuses
like the young ecosocialists
or the lgbtq caucus
politicians really their people
with can either be politicians for
state office local office or they can be
green party politicians
and then several others a map
organization
states like california are both an
organization and a map so i use
python's multiple inheritance to create
map organizations
and then a whole bunch of templates so
what you'd like to do is allow the end
users to do some customization of the
look and feel so for that you they're a
bunch of
templates they can use in the browser
both for html
ace html is the ace editor allows you to
technical editing of
html secure html some of those reports
that you saw are actually secure so only
those people with authorization can see
what the progress is
css typically on a file system css don't
have children but here i do
a tree of css objects so it gets served
as a single css but then you
you edit each css piece as a separate
chunk that's very nice
and similar javascript javascript
folders in a moment i'll show you the b3
images and thumbnails
very powerful pug is
like camel i'll show you that in a
moment also and then i did a whole bunch
of stuff with python in the browser but
people don't see misinterest in that
okay so here are the b tree images
one of the things i have to do is not
only images but thumbnails of those
images and i'm not a graphics designer
so i didn't know how big they should be
and there are a lot of thumbnails and i
didn't want to have to go and regenerate
them every time
and so what i did is now here an image
unlike on a file system an image can
have children child images
so here we have the map of the us and
you can see the different child images
of different sizes
so if i access less social media image
which you need for twitter or facebook
then you get the full image
but for the um thumbnails
you can just do slash 400 wide slash
200y
100 wide and it returns the thumbnail of
that size that saves bandwidth and even
if that thumbnail doesn't exist
it it creates that thumbnail and stores
it and there's a little bit of security
on that so that
okay because you're going to be storing
a million different
thumbnails okay so that was b tree image
a great example
of using an object database instead of a
file system
and then pug templating this is like
hamel um on the right hand side you can
see some html on the left hand side you
can see pug
now html page is actually a tree and of
course
particularly for um bootstrap
menu bars those trees get very complex
and i get totally lost
so what i do with those is i edit them
in pug it's got uses indentation defined
hierarchy just like just like python
does
and so it's really much much easier to
edit plug than it is to edit
html particularly for complex bootstrap
menus
and so in fact the end users can
customize their bootstrap menus their
menus if they want to for their
particular branch of the tree
okay so remember i showed you a video
page for jake tonkel with this video
and in the upper left hand corner we had
the hierarchy so let's take a closer
look at that
this is the hierarchy and here we have
the top level
of the tree and on the right hand side
i'm going to show you roughly how large
the tree can be at this
level so howie hawkins map server and
maybe there's seven categories at the
root
on the right side i'm not going to focus
in on the right side but you can just
keep an eye on it to keep an
estimate of how big the tree is green
party map at directory well that takes
us up to
50 states so maybe 350 at that level
green party of california they had a lot
of content but
maybe on average seven items at this
level of the tree green party of santa
clara maybe less but still on average
maybe seven
items maybe five items in this level of
the tree
jake tonkel the candidate he had some
one virtual meetup
in reality he'd have a lot more
uh they just weren't tracked in the
database yet and then educate particular
videos so
once you have one two three seven levels
deep say you have about seven items in
every category some have more some have
less
you end up with about five million items
in this tree
and that's a huge amount you can have a
large number of people working on it but
you don't get lost you have a good sense
of where you are
but you have to make sure that they
don't step on each other's toes
so if we have a very rich security model
model it's a hierarchical security model
and so at any branch of the tree you can
assign editors so at the national branch
they can assign cal
they can create a california branch
assign somebody in california to the
editor
they can create a santa clara branch or
sign somebody in santa clara they can
create
a jake tonkel assigned somebody and jake
tonkel and jake thompson create some
videos and some events and put somebody
else in charge of that so you have a
rich security model
that works for very large distributed
organizations
so that's the end of the hierarchical
model that we use let's talk about the
core of this talk really the users
and what the impact was on the users so
the first thing is that the hand
the small data is hand curated we
crawled whatever data we could
but actually all the data we crawled was
also hand curated
and so here's our data curation team and
maybe there are five of us who did
most of the work and then a lot of
people helped on their individual
states and the five was filled in the
other states
it's really useful so you remember santa
clara
we had all the contact information here
we have the contact information for all
of the
local parties all of the candidates all
of you very shortly all the elected
officials
it's very very useful information
and the small data is really loved so i
asked my boss what he thought about the
project alex norway
project he said is ecstatic holly hart
the green party usccc
co-chair coordinated campaign committee
ccc really likes this
lots of other people really love what
we're doing
and boy i got the upset if we get it
wrong
we got a message from one state green
party that we'd added a candidate who
they had not endorsed oh they were upset
okay no problem we removed the candidate
oh man that canada was even more upset
about getting removed so people
really get upset if we get this data
wrong in fact right now the
entire green party is voting the ex the
senior committee is voting on exactly
what the policy is for what data is to
be included and what data is not to be
included
and of course small data is very
labor-intensive it's all this hand
curation
a lot of discussion and so you need a
lot of volunteers
um either that or you can generate a lot
of good jobs for people
um and then small data has to be managed
because we've got a whole team of people
entering it
so on the left hand side you can see our
management screen we tracked all the
different states and when the stake was
completed
um and then one of the states had a
problem so he marked it as
as incomplete and then the appropriate
person went and fixed that state
and then the project manager would track
every state and do some quality control
on each state it was as it was completed
and then but you also have to keep an
eye on things and particularly as more
and more users are using it so we have
this
management view and in this management
view you can see all the changes to any
particular branch of the tree
so that's really important you have to
make sure that maybe somebody's adding
spam to a branch just kind of
be able to audit transactions
okay so that's the user experience let's
talk about the small data itself
so the first thing is that small data is
very low noise
the data is hand curated that gets rid
of most of the problems
users give feedback a lot of users give
the feedback if they spotted something
wrong with their data
and then the other thing you want to do
is have views with higher signal to
noise ratio so on the left hand side
you can see the map of california and of
new york so for those state websites
they can just link to the state map and
so that's really much less noise
um the other thing we're starting to do
is you saw the
map legend across the top of the map so
there
um we can initially we selected for
parties or candidates and we're now
we're selecting
we're doing much more detailed so on the
top level you can see
local parties candidates awaiting
results election victories
uh lost elections party officers
and down below you can see actually the
next version which we haven't installed
yet
is where there's actually a much richer
search filter with
you can either say which organizations
you want to see which kind of
politicians and we're starting to
include not only green party politicians
but also socialists and maybe
independents certainly independents and
maybe also progressives
so um that'll give make it a much more
useful and each of those there's a link
so for example um the young socialists
caucus within the green party will be
able to link to a particular url
and will only show all the caucuses
all the young ecosocialist caucuses all
across the united states so then the map
you get a whole
suite of maps for different
organizations so by reducing the noise
you make it much more useful to
all of the different viewers
and then small data small maybe many
people don't even recognize this they
call this a floctical it would only take
about 20 data bytes
20 megabytes not counting the images
um the core data would fit on on half of
optical so the the data is really quite
small
and it's really fast for those who are
international they may not recognize
this as the roadrunner who is so fast
that wiley coyote could never catch her
but because everything gave me cached in
memory
the application runs really quickly and
furthermore
um for the anonymous user everything is
cached behind
a caching web server
currently caddy shortly nginx
okay so because it's so small we don't
need a big server farm
we only take a fraction of the server um
a virtual private server
during the election it was uh four
gigabytes of ram 80 gigabytes of
drive about 20 dollars a month i think
after the action the traffic is going to
go way down 20 dollars
if maybe even five dollars a month will
be sufficient lino does a brilliant job
a lot of people like digitalocean
and so because it takes a much less of a
server it consumes much less energy
there's a huge problem with climate
change it's not just the polar bears are
hurting uh
millions of people all around the world
are already climate refugees wars water
wars
it's just going to get uglier very fast
how much energy does the internet
consume well i don't know i see
different numbers i don't think that's
as high as 10
although i've seen that claim i don't
think that the large
um internet giants wouldn't really want
to release how much energy they consume
and even if they move to renewable it
still takes a huge amount of
energy to create all of those renewable
energy resources
so whatever we can do to reduce energy
consumption we really should do and
small data is a great way to do that
and once you're being efficient you may
as well have small codes so not counting
the 55 third-party libraries which
i don't have to touch there's only 12k
lines of python code so
massive code reuse
um and the whole thing was done by one
developer
maybe my view from home is not quite
that nice
and remember it's not just a single
application it's multiple applications
it's the national map
state maps it's directories instant
backup websites
news sites a recommended voting list
there's a content management system
that's a discord so
a huge amount of functionality can be
achieved by
good software design software reuse
okay so that's ends the section on
the small data a few remaining remarks
um on data science
so the maps were really useful my boss
spent huge amount of time looking at
them not quite sure why his boss said
that he never understood
the illinois green party until he really
spent time with the maps
we did some analysis of which state
parties are the most
active the most interesting analysis was
two different spreadsheets i copied and
imported
um and they were off and it turns out
that there there's
because of that we realize that
different people have different policies
as to who
is a green party and who is not a green
party and so now we're
developing a policy document as to who
is included as an official green party
member on the map and who is a
non-official green party member on the
map
okay so when do you use small data when
you want to avoid big data
during global warming wherever possible
please use small data
and we're in a global warming period on
a niche topic
so all the awesome lists on
github uh green party united states
soon global green parties they're all
niche topics
if you're doing google for the whole
internet and it's going to be hard to
take this approach it's particularly
good in indexing the web there's so many
pages which ones do you want access to
use a human to to curate them link to
the important ones great
high noise environments there's also a
lot of spam on the web so for very
high noise environments human curation
is great for eliminating those
so if you have a situation where machine
learning doesn't work try the small data
approach
and also i think it really leads to a
better user experience the data's so
high
quality there's such a good signal to
noise ratio i think users really love
this
let's see how much time i have remaining
to discuss the software tools i used
uh three two minutes left not much
um i guess the big thing is i'm
increasingly not using the file system
and i am using an object database
uh to store like all the templates
and so the file system the hardcore file
system started off in multix in 1965.
actually i used multix
but it's really ancient so files don't
have children
and um directories
well they don't have attributes they
don't have methods and you can't send
them a
message so using a object database
wherever possible i think it was a huge
huge boost to the productivity lots of
other great tools here anyhow ask me
questions later if you if you want for
any questions about the software tools
so finally some links uh you can see the
website at
map.howie2020.tech forestwiki.com
slides will get you all the slides and
python links dot info
contact to contact me and i am starting
to do these classes
on json schema
if you're interested in a free class for
your local meetup please contact me
thank you